- [Narrator] High up in the Cordillera
mountains in the Philippines,
in the village of Buscalan, lives a woman
who is the last of her kind.
(foreign language)
(bustling village)
- Mambabatok is the name
given to the traditional
tattoo artist of the Kalinga ethnic group.
The artists are masters of
their thousand-year-old trade.
Originally giving tattoos to
warriors who won in battle.
(foreign language)
(tapping)
- Every year thousands of
tourists make the journey
to see Whang-Od and get
one of her famous tattoos.
(foreign language)
- Whang-Od is now the last
mambabatok, but she's teaching
her grand niece to carry
on the family tradition.
(foreign language)